Lauren is with us in Texas
Merry Christmas Lauren how can I help hi
Merry Christmas Eve my husband and I
have a question we are just getting
started on baby step two and we're about
to receive about a ten thousand dollar
settlement from an accident and so
originally we were planning to put that
all Polish baby step two but we are
debating now because our our AC unit are
heating an area unit went out again
today we have to go to a place and over
the last two summers it's gone out and
we've had to have work and repair done
on it I believe it's about 17 years old
I think it was what the house was built
so we're just wondering if we should go
ahead and put all that towards debt and
just hope nothing happens over the
summer or should we set some aside and
plan to help that you know replaced
because every time someone comes out of
course they're always telling us they
don't know how much it's gonna last
well sure they're trying to show you a
unit the I mean the repair upgrade the
replacement is a standard heating and
air process what what what went wrong is
last time what's the repair cost today
they came out they replaced the motor
and it was $250 okay what's your
household income um I think they take
home we bring home so my income
fluctuates on the walnuts we probably
bring in like $4,500 a month so your
household incomes like $70,000 a year
give or take okay about and how much
debt do you have not counting your home
about seventy five thousand on what um
about thirty student loans forty credit
cards and the rest on a car 430 and
student loans what about 30 on student
loans I guess no credit cards forty
reading words okay ouch
our credit cards are the problem how
long you been working on this how long
have you been doing Dave Ramsey debt
snowball gizelle intense
we're completely focused but we have not
been to balance to be okay that's what I
was that's kind of what I was sensing
and so there's a two or three things
that go into this all right
there's the practical aspect of the
question that you asked to replace
you're eating an air you don't want to
be without heating and air in Texas you
don't be without air in the summer
that's a bad problem you probably can
fix that and patch it up for another
three or four hundred dollars if it
comes up again and you can pull that
together out of your budget if you have
that level of an emergency and keep on
trucking it's not going to kill you
the other aspect though is something
happens when you sell out to the idea
mmm-hmm when you sell out to the idea
you're either forced to or you just
choose to completely completely lean
into the idea where it's no longer safe
and I'm just going for it and that's
what putting the ten ten thousand on the
debt and rolling up your sleeves and
doing the budget super super tight for
the first time and really growling and
saying we're not going out to eat and
really growling and saying we're not
going on vacation and really growling
and saying I have enough purses and
enough shoes and really growling and
saying honey you can't buy any more
tools you've got enough and whatever it
is whatever it is that we've all been
just kind of it's okay we do a little
bit a little ad and Lily this Lilith and
suddenly we end up seventy-five thousand
dollars in debt making seventy thousand
dollars a year right and that's how
that's how forty thousand dollars in
credit card happens it wasn't one stupid
thing
it was death by a thousand cuts wasn't
it yes and when you sell out emotionally
you're going the opposite direction from
the death by a thousand cuts because
there's a kind of a visceral sense of
positive desperation does that make any
sense yes in other words the way it
makes the way it kind of makes you feel
scared when you put the whole ten
thousand towards this debt with that
limping heating and air system that kind
of thing down inside of you is kind of
like edgy and raw and scared that's the
thing that drives you on out of debt
that means you've sold out right in a
good sold out into the system you know
and you're gonna go do this it's like
you know and and there's there's
something to that that's not all
mathematics and practical that that I've
that I've watched people do for 30 years
and and when they become unreasonable
they get unreasonable results that's
what I'm trying to say and so I would
put the whole ten thousand towards it
and I would double down on my commitment
and my visceral reaction to this
situation and I would just start you
know getting up early and working late
and I would sell everything in sight
where the kids think they're next and we
would cancel vacations and we're not
doing this and don't even talk to me
about seeing the inside of a restaurant
unless you're working there and you're
getting this mess cleaned up that's what
I would do yeah
I understand the logic of what you're
laying out but the logic of what I'm
saying also works and it actually works
better you've got to lean into this to
get the results that you hear people get
with these debt-free screams here on the
air really good question though thank
you for joining me let me talk that
through with you